over the past several years apple has
dominated the top of the fortune 500
from being the first company to reach a
1 trillion valuation to being the first
company to reach a 3 trillion valuation
much of this success is often credited
to steve jobs which makes sense given
that he was the visionary who gave apple
some of its most iconic ideas and
attributes with that being said though
tim cook has now been the ceo of apple
for over 10 years and during that time
period he's had some of the best
execution and the least drama of any
silicon valley executive from overseeing
apple's foray into services to leading
new product launches such as the apple
watch airpods the m1 chip and
potentially soon the apple car and apple
glasses there's no doubt that apple
wouldn't be what they are today without
tim cook but it seems like cook's
journey at the top is nearly coming to
an end rumors suggest that cook is
looking into a succession plan and that
he'll retire after he oversees the
launch of one more major product
category considering this i thought it
would be a great time to look back at
cook's past and analyze how he became
the ceo of apple
taking a look back tim's story dates
back to november 1st 1960 to a small
town in alabama called mobile he grew up
with two brothers named gerald and
michael in a pretty average american
household tim's father donald worked at
a shipyard while his mother joel dean
worked at a pharmacy it seems that his
parents were strong christians as tim
would be baptized as a kid
anyway tim would end up attending
robertsdale high school where he quickly
became a star student he graduated rank
2 in his class and he would enroll in a
local state college called auburn
university while tim always wanted to
work at a computer company it doesn't
seem like he wanted to be a programmer
or a tech person per se
it seemed like he was always more
interested in the operation side of
companies and appropriately he majored
in industrial engineering one of his
first jobs after graduation was at ibm
where he mainly worked on their supply
chain while working at ibm tim also
secured an mba from duke university in
1988 this allowed him to climb the
corporate ladder even quicker and tim
soon became a north american fulfillment
director at ibm
despite this rapid progress though tim
decided to leave ibm after 12 years at
the company in 1994 tim was hired as the
ceo of a small computer retailer named
intelligent electronics he worked here
for the next three years before jumping
over to compact computer corporation as
vice president
around the same time apple was doing
extremely bad
revenue was diving off a cliff and the
company was on the verge of bankruptcy
meanwhile steve jobs had been away from
the company for over a decade it wasn't
until apple agreed to acquire next
software that steve would return to
apple originally steve was just supposed
to be a temporary ceo but it quickly
became clear that no one else was better
for the role especially given the
circumstances as steve assembled a new
executive team to hopefully revive
apollo one of the people he invited to
join the company was of course tim cook
at first tim wasn't sure if he was
actually going to join apple but one
thing he was sure of was that he would
at least meet with steve jobs like many
of us tim himself was a massive fan of
steve who he thought was a creative
genius but at the meeting steve talked
to tim about his vision for what would
eventually become the imac and after
hearing steve describe his vision tim
knew he was gonna do it when tim shared
this news with his friends and family
they all thought that he was crazy to
give up an executive role at an
established computer company in order to
join one that was nearly extinct was
completely irrational tim admits that
there's no way to logically justify his
actions but with that being said it tim
also knew that working with steve was a
once in a lifetime opportunity so tim
listened to his gut and joined apple in
1998
despite joining a company that's known
for their beautiful products and ui tim
never really worked on either of these
aspects he knew that his expertise was
within the supply chain and that's where
he focused his efforts as senior vice
president of worldwide operations tim's
first order of business was purging
apple's existing supply chain to reduce
complexity tim slashed the number of
supply chain vendors from over a hundred
down to just 24. he also reduced the
number of warehouses by half and he
started shifting apple towards contract
manufacturing
contract manufacturing it is basically
when you hire third-party companies to
handle various parts of the production
and assembly process like tsmc and
foxconn these companies also work with
dozens of other tech companies which
allows them to reach extraordinary
economies of scale aside from clearing
up the supply chain tim spent a lot of
his effort on inventory management one
of the crown jewels of apple's supply
chain is just in time or jit
manufacturing and its roots can be
traced back to tim
jit manufacturing is the idea of
eliminating inventory in an ideal jit
implementation stores would carry
absolutely no inventory this isn't to
say that you can't go to the store and
buy the given product
if you were to go to the store the
product should ideally arrive at the
store seconds before you buy it
obviously this isn't very realistic but
tim was able to leverage jit to reduce
apple's inventory from weeks of
inventory to less than 5 days worth of
inventory
this might not sound like a big deal but
if you've ever run a business and
especially a small business you know
that buying and storing inventory is
extremely expensive take the iphone for
example apple stopped releasing unit
sales numbers for the iphone 8 years ago
but let's just assume that it's 100
million units per year
if apple were to store five weeks worth
of inventory they would have to sync
five billion dollars in inventory if
apollo only had to store five days worth
of inventory though they would only have
to sink 685 million dollars into
inventory
again this doesn't really matter that
much today as they have plenty of cash
but back in the early 2000s this was
crucial to cutting costs
and with the help of contract and
charity manufacturing which reduced
costs and the help of the imac and the
ipod which increased revenue apple was
finally able to regain profitability
this allowed steve to focus on the
iphone which was of course a massive
success but all was not good steve was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer which
made it rather difficult for him to
juggle apple and his personal health at
one point steve actually needed a liver
transplant and some sources suggest that
tim offered to donate a portion of his
liver but steve declined the offer while
steve declined tim's offer as steve's
health continued to decline he delegated
more and more tasks to tim until tim was
eventually made interim ceo in 2009
steve would come back later that year
but in early 2011 he would take another
medical leave of absence before he
eventually resigned in august of 2011
which made tim cook the permanent ceo
the first few years of tim's leadership
were rather easy given that iphone
adoption was still yet to peak there
were also plenty of new obvious features
to introduce like touch id and a larger
screen but iphone sales would eventually
not only peak but start to decline and
this is when tim's skills as a ceo would
really be put to the test tim addressed
his decline with the two-fold solution
and the first part was making apple a
lifestyle company while apple products
have always been expensive it wasn't
till the last couple of years that
iphone started getting a reputation for
being overpriced now don't get me wrong
here people have criticized the price of
the iphone since the day that it was
launched but i think the price argument
has shifted substantially initially the
argument had less to do with the device
itself being overpriced and more to do
with it being too expensive for the
average person to buy
today the argument has shifted more
towards the device itself being
overpriced but ironically entry-level
iphones are actually cheaper than ever
before
apple also keeps around older
generations for longer than ever before
and the iphone se starts at 429 which is
cheaper than the original iphone
i think all of this is part of tim's
strategy to maintain an apple's
exclusive image if apple's presentations
focused on how their entry level phones
are cheaper than ever before that would
likely degrade apple's image however by
focusing on the pro and the pro max
versions that cost over a thousand
dollars tim is brilliantly able to get
the media to paint apple's products as
exclusive and desirable i believe other
overpriced products like the apple
wheels and the pro stands serve the same
purpose these products simply define
apple's image while apple's real revenue
drivers are their cheaper products aside
from crafting this genius balance
between brand image and practical
products tim also reduced apple's
dependence on the iphone by embracing
services icloud apple music and apple tv
have all been massive hits for apple as
of october 2020 apple literally had 585
million paid subscribers even if each of
these subscribers only pay apple five
dollars per month we're talking about
nearly three billion dollars in revenue
per month and 35 billion revenue per
year considering this it's not
surprising that apple's revenue figures
are higher than ever before even though
iphone sales peaked seven years ago
aside from these services providing
apple with a great source of revenue
these services also strengthen the apple
ecosystem and make it harder and harder
for users to leave and i think these
three factors are what will become tim's
legacy at apple he defined apple's brand
image he significantly reduced the
dependence on iphone sales and he
crafted the apple ecosystem
looking forward it it looks like tim is
excited to release one more product
which is likely either the apple glasses
or the apple car
the glasses would be a major step into
the ar market while the car would be a
major step into the ev and autonomy
industries either product could be a
great send-off for tim but if the final
product is the car then tim will likely
have to stick around for a lot longer
after all scaling ev production is no
easy task and given that tim has
publicly announced that he probably
won't be ceo in 10 years i'm inclined to
believe that his last product is likely
the air glasses launching an ev vehicle
would simply be a much longer commitment
not to mention the ar glasses are much
more aligned with apple's other products
the car is completely out of left field
and apple really has no prior experience
in even building a car also they've
already experienced several delays and
hurdles along the way and i wouldn't be
surprised if this project was scrapped
altogether
so the most likely scenario is that we
see apple glasses roll out in 2025 or
2026 followed by tim cook resigning near
the end of the decade in terms of a
successor the fan favorite seems to be
craig federighi which is not surprising
given his charisma and stage presence
but many experts feel that craig is
better suited to continue leading
software development as opposed to
becoming ceo
i gotta say though if craig did become
ceo apple's presentations would be quite
fun almost like steve jobs presentations
but we'll just have to wait and see in
the meantime apple stock has already
grown 10x under tim's leadership so at
this point for tim it's just a matter of
wrapping up his journey with a bow and
saying farewell when do you guys think
tim will retire and who do you think
will replace him comment that down below
also drop a like if you're excited for
tim's last product and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one